Salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésor, aujourd'hui on est toujours en Allemagne
Sous un pont de criminel, encore une fois, bien à l'écart, mais à côté d'une grande ville.
C'est ça, on est à côté de Leipzig.
Pendant que Quentin s'amuse dans les joncs, moi j'ai enfin quelque chose qui était bien au milieu.
On va regarder ce que c'est.
Ouais, si, on a quelque chose qui arrive.
Oh la pelle !
Elle est d'époque !
Plurée !
Regarde !
Ah, elle est belle, hein ?
C'est de la bonne qualité, non ?
Ouais, ouais, c'est du bois, le manche, comme ça, là.
Magnifique !
Ah bah, c'est bon, je suis content.
Ça commence bien.
Allez, là, je crois que j'ai quelque chose.
Ca a un poids intéressant.
Oula !
On va garder la surprise jusqu'au bout, là, on dirait.
D'accord.
Ok.
Un pot en fonte.
Pas que, mais...
Une casserole avec des petites fleurs.
Et avec ça,
une grosse boule qui n'est pas un explosif.
Ça aurait pu, mais non.
C'est de la fonte.
Maintenant, j'aimerais bien trouver une pioche.
Ça, ça a été filmé.
Heureusement qu'il s'est pas collé, hein ?
T'es content avec la balle ?
T'as quelque chose ?
Allez, je te filme.
Pendant qu'Rasta y joue.
Une capsule
Rasta, regarde ce que j'ai trouvé.
Une munition de 9 mm.
Ça, c'est intéressant.
Très intéressant.
Donc, je vais continuer.
Et ce morceau de pont
Ça, par contre, j'espère pas en faire d'autres.
Là, regardez ce que je viens de sortir.
Déjà, bonbonne de prototype d'azote.
Ah non, c'est du CO2 pour les pistolets à bille
Peut-être pleine
Ouais.
Oui, mais c'est vrai que c'est bon signe la bonbonne de CO2.
Si il y a une pistolet à bille dans le coin.
Là, j'ai eu quelque chose qui était bien dans la vase.
J'espère que ce n'est pas encore un morceau de pont
Ah non.
Oh, c'est bizarre.
Une disquette.
Oh, et encore une munition de 9 mm.
Mais la disquette, c'est une première.
Je ne sais pas si ça résiste bien à l'eau.
Je ne pense pas.
Sympa, sympa.
9 mm par un parabellum
Ouais, sûrement.
Oh, un vieille arrosoir
Bon, il est totalement mort.
Ça, ça date de l'époque où ils jetés n'importe quoi.
Il n'en reste rien.
Là, il y a quelque chose.
Qu'est-ce donc ?
Il y a une marque.
Made in Germany.
Un bras articulé.
Franchement, je ne sais pas ce que c'est.
C'est un cadenas.
Ah, c'est un cadenas ?
Ah oui, peut-être.
Ah oui, il a été coupé alors là.
Là, il a été cassé, ouais.
Cadenas de vélo.
Mais oui, il était comme ça.
Ouais.
Bon, ça, c'est le classique sous les ponts.
Ok.
Ah, encore une munition.
C'est bon signe.
Troisième.
On vient de passer de l'autre côté du pont.
Et on dirait que ça a été fait.
Regarde ce qu'ils ont sorti.
Ça, c'est...
Comme des batteries, non ?
Ah oui.
Regarde.
Il y a plusieurs.
Tu es sûr que c'est aimanté tout ça ?
Mais c'était là-dedans, je pense.
Tu vois la forme.
Ça doit être toxique un peu.
Non, Rasta !
Tu laisses.
C'est étonnant
Rasta.
Non, tu creuses.
Ah, t'as ta balle.
Non, il est tombé dans l'eau.
Tiens.
Allez
Si, si, il y a quelque chose là.
Il y a une grosse barre.
Je vais essayer de la reprendre.
Et ça, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Un appareil électrique avec des grosses piles
purées la dépollution.
Des grosses piles énormes.
Et la grosse barre, elle est là.
Ok.
Bon bah, il y a des choses.
Il y a plus de choses, hein.
Enfin, en tout cas, pour ma part, c'est beaucoup mieux.
J'ai eu une munition, mais elle s'est cassée en deux.
On peut voir encore la poudre à l'intérieur qui a pris l'eau.
C'est intéressant de voir que au bout d'un moment
quand même, elles explosent.
Rasta, qui a perdu sa balle, le pauvre.
En fait, elle a coulé parce qu'elle était coupée en deux.
Là, on a quelque chose.
Oh, un rétroviseur de scooter.
Ou de petite moto.
Intéressant.
Ça va viens ?
Allez, enfin, quelque chose.
Le perd pas.
Ouais, ça bulle bien là-bas, au fond, encore.
C'est hyper lourd.
Je crois que c'est un morceau de pont.
En fonte
Non.
C'est une petite caisse.
C'est quoi cette petite caisse ?
Je crois que c'est un piquet
Ça appartient au truc, ça ?
Non.
Non, c'est un petit...
Tu crois que ça s'ouvre ?
Je sais pas.
Il y a des aérations un peu comme un appareil électronique, mais bon.
C'est que c'est que ça
Ouais, il y a un truc dedans, je pense.
Mais c'est pas une batterie, non ?
Ouais, ça doit être surtout de la vase dedans, mais bon.
Ouais.
Je sais pas comment on peut l'ouvrir, hein.
On a le pied de biche dans la voiture, au pire.
C'est super dur.
Bon, on l'ouvrira en fin de vidéo.
Ouais.
On le garde
Ouais, un ragondin dans l'eau, tu feras attention.
Là.
Bon là, les gars, je suis content parce que j'ai fait ma première monnaie allemande.
Regardez-moi ça.
Il y a la même feuille que sur les euros,
mais on a bien marqué Dutchland.
Toujours à la recherche de sa balle.
Ça va, Rasta ?
Elle est où, la balle ? Elle est où ?
Cherche.
Une pièce.
C'est une ancienne pièce allemande, je pense, elles vieillissent très mal.
Un panneau.
Et encore une munition.
Regardez l'état de ces munitions, elle se casse directement en deux.
Ça date vraiment de la guerre.
Et vous voyez, il y a la poudre intérieure en cristaux.
Et ça, c'est le panneau.
Ah ouais.
C'est pour la température d'eau ?
Pas la température, la profondeur d'eau.
Ok.
Oh là, il y a un enjoliveur
Oh ho, calibre 12.
Ah, ça c'est intéressant.
Ouais.
Trap 24 super.
12 / 70
Pleine
Et une plaquette de frein
Je vais continuer à tirer un peu là.
Ce pont est plein de munitions mais pas d'armes
Compliqué.
Là, on assiste à une course.
Allez.
On va voir ce qu'on a.
Enfin, à l'heure de pêche qui est potable en plus.
Il est beau.
Il est très beau.
Encore une ogive.
Ça ne suffit pas, c'est des indices, mais ça ne suffit pas.
Allez, là, on a quelque chose.
Le dernier espoir un petit peu.
C'est blanc.
Il se vide.
C'est comme toi, un peu, la boite
C'est vide en plus.
Attention.
C'est bon, ça s'ouvre pas en haut, là.
Du cuivre, normalement, non?
C'est un appareil électronique.
Ouais, mais...
Ouais, on dirait.
Faut l'ouvrir
Une batterie dedans qui peut exploser
Tu ne peux pas l'extraire, là ?
Wow.
Il y a un aimant.
Comme une enceinte, ouais.
Ouais il y a un aimant.
C'est un aimant, je pense.
Ouais.
Il est puissant !
Il est super puissant, ouais.
D'accord, ben...
C'est un bel aimant.
Un bel aimant, ouais.
Il marche mieux que l'aimant Wish qu'on a repêché en Allemagne
Oui on a repêché pas mal d'aimants.
Que l'on n'a pas gardé, parce que, bon...
Mais celui-là, il est costaud, ouais.
On pourrait presque pêcher avec.
Du coup, c'était une partie d'enceinte,
Peut-être pas
Un appareil qui utilise un aimant
Ouais.
Ah ouais.
Franchement.
Ok.
Bon, finalement, on n'est pas si déçu que ça.
Ça aurait pu être pire
Attends, je vais y arriver, quand même.
Wow.
Regardez la force.
Un aimant au moins dix kilos, ça, attends.
Ça rigole pas, hein.
Ouais.
Pas mal.
Allez, à la semaine prochaine.